Oh George Takei is in this one hahahaha
um I don't ever remember him laughing
like that but everybody does then the
impression so uh but okay well well of
course get to him in a second uh this is
the episode called imprisoned Gotha is
much easier to say title you know some
of these titles are like you know legend
Oh cubby Bobby II or the temple of who
seek ah so it is nice just in prison
short easy um alright so this episode uh
for those who don't know even if you do
now just reminder um pretty much they go
to a place where they find this boy who
can Earthbend and it's in a land where
it's forbidden cuts it's taken over by
the Fire Nation they don't want anyone
to do any of this any pending whatsoever
and I guess the main focus of this world
is or this land is earthbending
they find this boy who's doing orth
bending and uh oh now if we're gonna
have to say her name uh Katara is that
yak I would tonic antara that I'll
remember okay so um so she befriends
this boy um and is telling him not to be
ashamed of his powers and he uses it to
save a guy from getting crushed and the
guy turns a man I love that I love it
when even the person being saved is like
I still got my ethics I know this is
wrong I think they think their ethics
are in the right place but the Thole is
cute um so they go to this prison again
great design for this prison I love it
uh and Katara is gonna sneak in or get
herself captured through a very funny
scene again I think a lot of humor in
this is kind of getting better the last
episode was kind of weak but the humor
in this one is better um and she gets
herself tossed in and tries to save him
but on top of that save his father and
encourage the people to fight back
because all the prisoners in this world
are pretty much like just beaten they're
waiting for you know either something to
happen or just death take them uh and
what I really like about it the two
things are like about this episode 1 is
of course George Takei as the as one of
the prison guards or as like the guy in
charge of the prison which is just great
because it's um you know it we know him
so much for comedy now but I like the
fact that this performance is sort of a
it's a good mix of comedy and
intimidation he actually can be a little
intimidating um which I enjoy but but it
levels out you know just right like
there's a guy who is questioning him and
he throws him over the edge Isis you
know look the captain of my orders and
guards if that was the captain says oh
well alert somebody I haven't thrown
overboard and that that's a good joke
but it also shows how funny he can be to
that he would just throw a person over
like that he has his nice long-winded
speeches you know about how great he is
and how pathetic you are so it's you
could totally tell he's just soaking up
that role and and it's a lot of fun it
never quite goes too far over the top
it's just the right mix uh and the other
moment I really like I like the moment
where I'm well first of all it's very
much a Katara episode which is nice
and not that she has been doing stuff in
the our episodes but it's nice to have
one where she really sort of saves the
day in this one she really rallies
people together
um and I love the way they get out with
the coal and how they shut off I love
that ingenuity I love that creativity
and it's so smart um and just the
abilities they have and how they
incorporate them into the world but uh
she gets up there she makes this great
big speech to these these prisoners you
know saying you know really fight now
because there will not be an hour time
you only get one life go out there you
know be who you are and stuff like that
and you know it's sort of building up to
a dumbell joke like they're not gonna do
anything or they're just gonna roll
their eyes or laugh or something like
that but what I like about the scene is
that it isn't just you know a wat why Jo
you don't hear that stupid whistle I
hate that stupid wizard I've it said
before by the way David like though I
hate that whistle it is not needed I
know they're doing a new series now so
just keep that whistle out if again um
but it's actually a legitimately
sad scene they don't even have the
energy or you know the influence or just
any amount of caring to even acknowledge
her too
even roll their eyes or say no you're
silly don't even do I mean they just the
most they do is turn their heads and
look at her and when she's done they
just turned back and there's such a
sadness to that and not just for her
being rejected but for these people
because it's just so been beaten out of
them uh and it happens twice to which I
like um you know and then finally when
you know one does fight back in another
fights back and so on so forth you know
it's it makes sense because you know
it's the the boy who fights back and
then the father and then you see them
rally behind those two because they they
know those two and like those two at
least know the father and obviously the
son now um so it makes a little bit more
sense it isn't just like a random yeah
let's just do what the heck do a sex
mocking up you know sort of thing it
actually does have a legit build up to
it uh so I really enjoy that again this
is a really good it's another really
good strong episode uh and the comedy is
much better you know with the the kid is
it Sokka is that the kids name I always
call him the brother I'm getting these
names down you know I'm trying to get
them down you know stupid white American
you know if it's a name that's not my
language I'm like so apologies for that
um somebody make us still that face I
just made I'm sure it's funny uh so
every a lot of people been saying like
you know come on lay off this kid come
he's not that bad he's not that bad I
like just make something clear the voice
actor is fine the voice actor is
actually a little too good in my opinion
because a lot of times like particularly
in the first episode the first couple
episodes it's like a lot of lines he's
saying I'm like well that's not a funny
line but he's kind of saying it funny
you know like if I his delivery so good
I want a stronger punch line at the end
of the sentence because he says in a way
where you know it's building and then
there's not much of a payoff but he's
getting uh the characters getting
funnier in this one there was some
really good legit funny moments
particularly when they're trying to fake
the earth-bending I I thought was very
humorous um or in the opening where he
has the rock say he suggests that biggie
rocks uh you know or no no not Rock said
nuts and they finds a rock that
he thinks is another very Rock looking
nut that is most likely a rock you know
I mean that stuff's great so it it seems
like that's getting better which is good
because in the last episode I mean not
that was entirely not funny but I'll so
like okay so was the episode before that
just kind of a flu could you know with
the good humor it's trying to come up no
it still seems like they got some really
funny moments I see a lot of people like
saying oh wait to see the cabbage guy
I'm like aah guy and I realize it must
have been the episode before this guy
just shouting my cabbage and I don't
know if he comes back um but I thought
the foaming mouth guy was funnier I love
the fact that show has cat you know
means our cabbage guy and foaming mouth
guy I think that's hilarious um but now
I'm really getting out track here so
another great episode I love at the end
when the Prince comes in as on their
track and you sort of forget it past
like oh yeah him and then it's like oh
no he's on their trails I get it
however they do it it sucks you in and I
like getting sucked in by this world in
these characters um and it's it's a fun
world and fun characters to get sucked
into it's not so I came of Thrones where
I love Game of Thrones I still love it
but where it's something like oh let me
get sucked in so I can be incredibly
depressed and just be like god please
just somebody win something you know I
like this world because I like seeing
them win I like seeing them succeed and
I like seeing them get closer but they
still had to get through these obstacles
and they're good obstacles and they're
good villains and all the good stuff so
again I'm just going over the show in
general another great episode really
enjoy it
we'll see you in the next one